notice some disturbing new developments
in the case of four murdered students at
the University of Idaho all four were
killed with some type of Blade but no
murder weapon was found and police are
now walking back earlier statements that
there's no further threat Christina
raffini is in Moscow Idaho where police
are asking for help from a community
that is already on edge Christina good
morning
good morning David there's a small
memorial set up in front of the house
here and a squad car keeping watch
meanwhile the local police have set up a
tip line asking anyone in the public who
might have any information about what
happened here to please come forward
we cannot say that there's no threat to
the Community Police in Moscow Idaho
walked back previous statements that
there's no ongoing danger and responded
to criticism over an initial lack of
information I probably should have been
standing here a day or so ago but I'm
here now law enforcement said there were
no signs of forced entry and two other
roommates were home but not harmed in
the pre-dawn attack but authorities
weren't called until the next day we
don't know why that call came in at noon
and not in the middle of the night to
help find the person or persons
responsible investigators are trying to
piece together the victim's timeline
Saturday night they say they know Ethan
Chapin and Zana Chernobyl were at a
party on Campus Madison mojen and Kaylee
Gonzalez were seen at a Downtown Bar
[Music]
this twitch live stream video appears to
show Madison and Kaylee chatting and
getting a late night snack from a food
truck hours before they were killed the
County prosecutor and police say they're
combing through the video trying to
identify people with whom they may have
come in contact in a statement the
galsanvez family tells CBS News Kaylee
and Maddie should still be here with us
this monster that took away their lives
and the lives of Zanna and Ethan need to
be punished and held responsible their
loss has been devastating and they were
bright lights in our community
and are deeply missed and remain in our
thoughts and our prayers
with the situation here so uncertain a
lot of students left campus early before
the break so a planned Memorial will now
be held after Thanksgiving Nate
Christina thank you it's so upsetting
Nate you know I've heard family members
say they have a lot of questions for
Idaho Police because of course they said
listen there's no danger to the
community which leads would lead you to
believe that they have some idea right
about who they're looking for now to say
there's a they don't know that there's a
suspect on the loose and everybody still
be honest the confusion still be on
guard very very Andy are two roommates
were in the house at the time of the
killing the slaughter rather and how do
you kill four people with a knife
because that's up close you wonder if
the feds are going to come in right step
in assist yeah so you'll see but we know
that they're dealing with a ton of pain